you it wasn't long ago the far left
anti-free speech lunatics at twitter and
facebook
they were censoring the truth about the
origins of covet 19 because it didn't
fit their
preferred pro-democratic socialist new
green deal narrative
now they're are renewed calls for these
tech giants to lose their special legal
protection
we've told you all about section 230.
joining us now with more
pretty good insight into all this
senator marco rubio of florida
senator by the way you have an important
race in 2022.
uh unless it hurts you i support your
winning
uh we need you in florida we need you in
washington so
thanks for being back with us i
appreciate it thank you let's get into
big tech withheld information about
hunter's laptop before the
election that that to me would be an
in-kind donation right
uh they're choosing sides why do they
get this protection
they've become the new sort of
gatekeepers of the public square in
american politics if you think about
we've never been here before
five companies in america now have the
power to basically wipe anybody out and
silence anyone you know
amazon google facebook twitter you know
they all get together and they decide
apple
they get together and decide we're gonna
wipe somebody out you're done there's
nowhere for you to communicate
you can't even get web services and you
can't communicate to the outside world
your views
more than that they now have put
themselves in a position of determining
what news can be re-reported we remember
those articles about hunter biden and
they quashed the new york post stories
they wouldn't let it
be spread and now for the first time
we've seen them have to go back
and remove a ban on stories about the
origins of the coven
19 uh virus because they've proven to be
untrue this is the danger here is you
have a bunch of unelected
unaccountable anonymous people deciding
what we're allowed to say to one another
and what we're allowed to share
that's a very dangerous moment they have
assumed basically governmental type
powers
without being accountable to anyone let
me ask you let me move on to the
coronavirus and what we're discovering
and what fauci knew and when he knew it
and gain a function and nih money going
to the wuhan institute of virology
i don't know about you senator but this
makes my blood boil
that in fact we could have actually paid
for this let me tell you
here's what we knew from the very
beginning right this is what we knew
from the very beginning and you put all
the circumstantial evidence together and
then it led to some
level of conclusion at least okay you
have a virus that we
know the chinese are experimenting with
in that lab in a lab we know that has
uh that has a safety problems we know
for a fact that
messing around with viruses and lab
accidents have led to
outbreaks in the past that happened with
sars uh
back in the day that two different
outbreaks from researchers that were
infected
and by the way coincidence out of
coincidence this outbreak started in the
very city where that lab is located
there isn't a bat cave in wukon's in
enormous cities like the size of
manhattan there's no bat caves there
and by the way under sars they found the
animal would spread it within four
months
under mers they found the animal that
spread it within nine months still to
this day
the chinese have not said this is the
animal that first spread it over to a
human being
you put all of that together and that's
why there are a lot of people that say
at a minimum at a minimum the the lab
leak theory is at least as
credible as the fact that it would carry
over naturally if not more so because of
the circumstantial evidence
let me ask you the same question i asked
lindsey graham with hunter's work and
now
joe's been proven to have lied to
everybody saying he never talked to his
son about his foreign business dealings
with no experience making all this money
in ukraine and kazakhstan
and russia and china
do we have to worry about this president
being compromised potentially on
national security issues
because i'm pretty certain that the
media the mob that they are uh if it was
a republican president
uh would be all over this um conflict of
interest shall we call it
and it will be the leading story it will
be the leading story in every outlet
tonight i pray if that were donald trump
i would be sitting in the senate right
now on a third impeachment trial
we would be in impeachment proceedings
right now it would be leading the
newscast
and every major media outlet in this
country except for maybe fox and a
couple others but it would be the top
story in the country they'd be all over
it
absolutely and i think it shows two
things it's something to be concerned
about
we need to learn more about this uh and
especially now this new evidence has
emerged
but i think it also exposes the
extraordinary hypocrisy journalism in
america is on its deathbed there's no
journalism anymore
these are activists masquerading as
journalists i actually said
journalism is dead in the year 2007
which probably means i've been on the
air too long
uh last question forgive me for asking
it you made comments recently about ufos
and i'm just intrigued by the topic and
i just wanted to you know
they're saying now oh there's no
evidence of that then you see all these
videos and
i'm beginning to think what is that well
we don't know and look i every time
people immediately start thinking about
extraterrestrials and little green men
we're not at that stage here what we're
saying is there are things that are not
ours there are things that are not ours
flying over military installations
be careful you got to be called racist
if you know
just saying is it the green part of the
little part
i have no idea probably on every side
they're talking about these things
flying around we just don't know what
they are we need to know what they are
all right i agree with you senator uh
we're going to be following your race
very closely it is critical
all right thank you for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else